this is Startalk hello and welcome to
Startalk I am dr. Nathalie Starkey and
this is Startalk Allstars I am gonna be
your all-star host today and joining me
as a co-host
I have comedian I yes it's gonna be fun
I think because today we are gonna be
talking about water in space I want to
just stress that I'm saying water water
water British water tea in the middle of
water water not water I'm getting you're
not have water you're actually talking
about that as well we're talking about
wowing yeah so what or two I guess I
want to talk about this subject because
it's quite important right we we drink
water all the time we don't litres of it
I'm gonna say that water is indeed the
most important substance on earth
whoever okay you said it okay I really
believe that there is nothing more
important than water I believe that is
where the origins of life stem okay I
believe that that is why it is the most
necessary thing to sustain life so it is
where life began and it is also where it
is also what sustains it and for some
reason we don't treat water like it's
important we need to respect the water
yes you are so right and it's a bold
statement but I think you know it's fair
enough we do need to respect but we need
to understand where it came from because
it does appear that earth is the only
planet in our solar system that has
liquid water on its surface now it's not
to say there isn't liquid water
elsewhere but not on the surface of
other planets it's probably ice now
there's loads of water in the solar
system but it's it's probably as ice now
importantly we think we need it as
liquid for life to store to star and
form and everything so why are we the
only planet with liquid water this is
one of the big research questions and
you know one of the questions we should
be asking I'm gonna say it's because
we're special we are
we are we are very special I mean just
look around the solar system okay we're
pretty damn special all right take that
Venus climate surface exactly right
crazy halls we are basically the Bahamas
of the solar system okay you know the
place you want to be it's the place you
wanna be
yeah it's true so okay to help us with
this subject today we have a world
experts on water in the solar system and
it is Linda Elkins tan Sun welcome to
the show that's alright we're really
glad you could join us now I'm gonna get
this right you're the director of the
school of Earth and space exploration is
that correct Arizona State University
exactly okay and what does your job
involve just directing people around the
university Lindy that's what directors
do I try to make it easier for the
scientists to do their jobs and answer
their big questions and a lot of people
here are working on questions just like
what you're talking about
why do we have water here why is there
not liquid water elsewhere why is the
earth not Venus thank goodness very cool
and your own research I mean you've got
a background in research as well and
that's what you've been looking at right
you've you've been looking at this kind
of how how we get water on planets and
all this business so you are gonna be
quite helpful I think the kids today
we're gonna be looking at cosmic queries
and answer some questions from the
peoples out there about this subject so
I think we should probably kick off and
see see how we go yeah let's jump right
into the questions here and I am going
to take one from Dylan Hallahan who is a
patreon patron if you're a patreon
patron what you get to do is send us a
question and we will give it priority
because if you're a patreon patron it
means that you have supported us
financially and you helped make this
whole thing happen
so it's actually addressed to both of
you doctor Elkins tantan and dr. Starkey
very formal very cool how likely would
it be for us to set up a workstation
in a Lagrangian fuel consumption and
keep equipment and safe location near
the moon Europa and be able to take
multiple trips to analyze the
composition or harvest the water that
lies beneath it now that Wow to start
off I'm gonna tell you right now to
start off the cosmic queries with that
that's the first of all that's a super
packed question question I mean that's a
huge question I mean this question
really has more parts it's like a
freakin cosmic cake before we get into
this let me just ask another question
lyndie what is water alright so we can
break it down break this down and get
into it first of all he's talking about
a workstation in a Lagrange's gonna
start fast with the rope apart okay I
think that's the better way to get into
this because you're the doctor first of
all why does he want to go to your
Reaper you know that's that's the big
question what is so interesting about
Europa it is very interesting because
what we think is happening there is that
there is liquid water but it's not at
the surface it's under a surface of a
probably water ice but the fact is that
there potentially and it quite likely is
water under the surface and this right
why do we say potentially am most likely
what what evidence do we have
Lindsey am i right in saying it's it's
not fresh water is it it's it's salty I
think is that right yeah so we think
it's salty hardly because fresh water is
really rare in our solar system and
there we think that the water is
actually in there's there's an icy crust
and then liquid water and then
underneath that rocky core and so the
water and the rock art
interacting and when geysers go up from
the surface it looks like they have salt
in them so it's not fresh water but it
still could be good for life yeah and
when you see it looks like it has salt
in them when the geysers you know create
their plume into space is that because
we're able to we're able to see that in
some form yeah so we can measure that
that materials that are coming off and
so they know that it's you know it's got
potentially some some elements in it
that look like it could be salty water
now I think as that planet is kind of
sounding a lot like Earth right we got
the Rockies you've got the oceans and oK
we've got ice on the surface in some
places so it is one of the key places in
the solar system that we are wanting to
go in the future to actually look for
life but first of all we need to
understand the you know the moon itself
a bit a bit more but this is I think why
this person is asking this question is
why we want to go there and it we
definitely do want to go there now the
second hard question in terms of setting
up a camp in an you know an orbit around
or something it's I guess that is gonna
be extremely challenging I mean I Lindy
I don't know what you you know about
this I think that would be I think first
of all we just need to probably do a
flyby and and potentially drop something
in so that we can work out what is going
on there but trying to you know get into
orbit around something that's so far
away that we don't know much about still
would be challenging that's right so
first we're just trying to send a
mission that's going to do a whole
series of flybys and look at Europa from
different points of view and right away
there's a giant challenge because there
is such strong radiation that we don't
even think the robotic spacecraft is
gonna survive for long
Wow let alone a person now that's a huge
huge challenge so that the radiation
itself would actually interfere with the
instrumentation yeah yeah we think it'll
break down the instrumentation I heard
someone say recently that if you could
put an unshielded person on the surface
of Europa they would die from radiation
poisoning in a matter of minutes it's
that strong that's wrong
yeah I don't think we want to hang
around
and and you know NASA always says you
have to limit the number of Technology
miracles that you remission and this
idea of going and hanging out in the
Lagrangian and that is zooming back and
forth that's that's I can't count that
high that's a lot of Technology miracles
that is all we need is all we need is a
starship with with shields that's it
yeah and you know what it's easy we'll
just do that you know in terms of the
gorge points I mean I think it's
something that we can think about around
the moon because this is a body we
understand a lot better and you know it
in terms of we we talk about asteroid
mining that's one of the ideas we
dragged something into low low moon
orbit and and then we can mine it and
it's a bit easier because it's closer to
us but when you try to extend this out
into the solar system it just gets so
much more complex and we know so little
about these objects that it's basically
impossible at the moment but you never
know in the future fact we need to take
small steps like the Apollo mission
small steps to get there eventually so
now I'm really fascinated by the fact
that the radiation is so strong that it
will actually impede the function of
instrumentation with that in mind is
there any attempt to create those
circumstances somewhere here close by
and then test instrumentation so that we
can send it there is is that a is that a
plan in the works at all yes absolutely
absolutely so so stay tuned because nASA
has every intention of sending a
flagship your own provision Europa
mission
there's no launch date yet but they've
actually chosen the instruments so we're
really trying to do this we are we're
really I said mission have a name at the
moment it's had several names I don't
know what its official one is and the
the controversy right now is do we do
what some of the congressional
supporters want and try to send a lander
okay is that too many technology
miracles and we're just gonna fly by
okay okay that sounds good we read this
but this isn't gonna be for a while or
are we no no there isn't there isn't
even a launch date yet I think we have
to get past Mars 2020 yeah
some other budget and see if there's any
money see that's where it all screws up
start asking for the money the funny
part is there's tons of money there's so
much money in the wrong places yes
exactly I mean seriously the billions of
dollars that we give in tax credits to
just one oil company I mean do you think
we could do this for about four billion
dollars do you think if I gave you four
billion dollars okay so there you go
that's one year that's one year of tax
credits Wow and you imagine that's one
year we could get this done that's crazy
okay don't get me started
all right here we go
okay I'm on that one for you okay lyndie
I'm on that one
all right okay here we go I like this
Nate Carlson from Ottawa Canada would
like to know this how did large moons
like Europa and Enceladus end up with so
much water while others like aisle are
mostly rock so he went from Jupiter to
Saturn and yeah better that we know our
water have a lot of water yeah yeah it's
been what you do think about most moons
you don't think of a moon as a place
with water you think of a moon as a dry
desert rocky crater filled you know
that's because we think of a moon you
know and that's what we see because it's
our closest neighbor and we look up and
we go oh it's there and it's dry and
rocky and you know fair enough right but
you know they're all different and
they're all formed in different ways and
so they've got you know different
origins and therefore they're gonna look
different forms so I mean I think part
of the question the answer here is
basically I think it's the proximity of
the moon's to their big planet so we
take Jupiter if you're really close to
Jupiter the effects that that massive
planet has on a moon are going to strip
away the atmosphere any water away from
that moon whereas I think am i right
Lindy in saying like your rape is
further away so it's managed to maintain
it's its water is that right I think
there's a mixture of things I think I
think you're right it depends on what
the history of the moon is you know was
it did it get was it from a giant impact
the way the Earth's was was it accretive
from material very close to the planet
or from farther away and then indeed how
does the planet affect it he doesn't
have its own magnetic field that helps
shield it or is it just fall victim to
being stripped of everything by by the
magnetic field of its larger planet okay
so all those things come together to
pretty much determine you know whether
or not and that's why you see it like it
I love the fact that he used Enceladus
along with Europa because now we have
two different moons two different
planets yeah and they do share those
characteristics exactly yeah oh yeah all
right hey Nick awesome man nice nice
question buddy nice question all right
let's go to Anna Magnus mungus sorry not
Magnus mungus all right it's a mongoose
baby i don't wants to know there's hello
this is honor from phoenix given the
fact that we only see life-sustaining
water in the few places in our solar
system how likely is it that in other
solar system galaxies there is water
like we have on earth oh yeah okay we
agree on that good job both of them got
excited at the same time you see you go
ahead
first of all yay Phoenix so this is
something I'm really obsessed with
obsessed the flutter does the water get
built into the planet through its normal
process of building up to planet size or
does it have to get added later we used
to be taught that the earth got its
water from comets that struck the
surface after the earth was pretty much
completely made and now we have lots of
evidence that that's not true oh really
lots of evidence that the water on the
earth came from rocky material the same
rocky material that built up the bulk of
the earth and if that's correct it's not
that later water was
at it I mean we still have stuff falling
to the earth today and adding water but
the point is it wouldn't be necessary
and so if it's true that the earth was
born wet then that means that rocky
planets everywhere in the universe have
a very good chance of being born what
and then the question becomes how long
can they stay that way there's some
lifetime to have an ability and it's not
going to be long enough everywhere let
me just say that that will be the name
of my first erotic rock-and-roll album
ha ha ha on wet secondly if you if you
could please tell me how you get water
from a rock aside from being Moses if
you could please tell me when you say
that you think the water was built into
the rock well yeah okay the thing is the
earth it was really really hot to start
with so this is what I don't understand
about these theories although I've read
Linda's papers obviously but it is still
hard to understand how we would trap all
that water in the earth when it was you
know thousands of degrees Celsius right
because water is a volatile and it's
gonna evaporate away so how do we keep
in the earth if it you know went through
there so water we think was delivered in
in crystals that had water trapped
inside the crystal like my god there's a
mineral that a lot of us have played
with and it turns out that their water
molecules actually trapped inside those
crystals only doesn't come as ice and it
doesn't come as liquid water it actually
comes as rock yes I'm crazy and then it
also turns out it's really hard to dry
things even if you melt that rock and
even if you melt it and race it up to
thousands of degrees there's still gonna
be a little bit of water stuck in that
liquid magma
because water just doesn't go away that
easily it likes to hold in so it doesn't
make sense ready it's fascinating I mean
honestly as a concept it it really does
the the the crystal itself is holding
the water it's holding I'm about to
unlock the water in the crystal because
the crystal is a crystal
you would have to superheat that crystal
to release the water molecule and that
if that didn't happen then you can
retain that water in the earth and then
it can stay that and then still water
can come in from elsewhere right meaning
what you end up with is a bit of a
mixture of potentially different sources
but actually you know some of it was
there from the beginning now obviously
we have or an out-of-time on this we can
come out very good we got a couple more
because there's you know there's plenty
more to be had here but for the time
being when it's okay going to take a
short break and we'll be back shortly
and welcome back to star talk all-stars
I am dr. Nathalie Starkey I still have
Chuck knives for me here and Linda
Elkins tanto and joining us from Arizona
yes actually cosmic queries after the
cosmic queries now you know we had to
take a little break but I really did
kind of step on on a mountain mongooses
question when i interject it my my
question about the crystals but let's
get let me just give her the proper do
okay
okay because here was her actual
question given the fact that we see
life-sustaining water in a few places
here in our solar system how likely is
it in other solar systems and galaxies
there is water like we have on earth so
okay that's the best the real crux week
we got off into the crystals and you
know that whole deal and that's is
fascinating and very important but
please go ahead and finish honors
question
okay so Lindy elsewhere I think you you
eluded before the you know yes it's
quite likely in the way we think the
water in earth is present but it was
trapped in the beginnings that actually
this could happen lots of times
elsewhere all throughout the universe
but we haven't have we seen any yet have
we actually detected it there's hints of
what's in the atmospheres of exoplanets
around stars far away but only about 12
of them have had any part of their
atmosphere measured yet so that's really
an unknown area for us all we can really
do right now besides work on making
those measurements is learn more about
how water is delivered to our planets
here in our solar system yeah yeah cool
yeah that is it it's a very far away
bars
I only believe there is life elsewhere
in the universe and that because there's
water I think there's just got to be
this place is so huge that you know it's
unimaginable but I think it's got to be
there now a couple years ago I saw this
I read this article and there was a
discovery and it was more of a postulate
than a discovery okay that there may be
when we consider all of the galaxies
that we know and and now with the
information that we have from the
imaging that's coming
that there might be as many as 600
million planets like Earth Wow is that
true and yes that is true
cool so that's very exciting and and so
with 600 million planets like Earth what
does that do to the likelihood of life
and even sentient life yeah I mean it's
a huge number to even imagine this is
like so I just it has to be that there
has to be life somewhere else I'm just
absolutely sure of it when we say the
earth light we should probably explain
why they're earth-like because we end up
we basically to get an earth we need a
planet orbiting a star that is it's kind
of the right distance away from the star
and it's got to be the right size stars
that's not too hot not too cold and that
this planet is at the right distance
that it could have liquid water on its
surface but it probably needs an
atmosphere there to contain it probably
is a magnetic field to keep it kind of
safe and and therefore it's kind of what
we call the Goldilocks zone so this is
you know the porridge that's sorry the
oatmeal whatever you call it here yeah
it's porridge as well not too hot not
too cold just perfect so that we have
the really good conditions like we have
on earth so these planets exist and
there's a lot of them we you know it's
hard finding them but that they're there
just cuz they're so far away but yeah
there are a lot of them I think they've
got to contain life what do you think
Lindy is there life out there I think
that there has to be I'm with you but
here's the thing that we really don't
know I I think we're pretty confident
that there are really a lot hundreds of
millions of billion planets like the
earth but how long does it take and how
unlikely is it for life to actually
start yeah we have evidence here on
earth that life only started on earth
one time even though we had the perfect
conditions right does that make it less
likely however I'm with you there has to
be life we don't yet know if there isn't
life elsewhere in the solar system I
mean absolutely there's no complex life
so we know that because I think we would
have seen it by now but you know it was
still looking at Mars that might have
been life in the past the other thing
that we have to take into consideration
though is that there could have been
life and it could be gone yes our solar
system will one day
begone yeah so there is very possible
that another solar system with the same
type of conditions as an earth planet
like ours came along and now we're
looking at that system as a part of a
black hole so yeah exactly
sorry yeah okay that'd be awesome
oh yeah you know I'm not gonna worry
about that because I got a feeling that
it might happen after I'm gone and I'm
that selfish
speaking of selfish here's a great
question from Travis sheaves we're gonna
bring it back to earth I know both of
you are you know concentrated on space
but here's a when we're talking water
space look at the earth to understand
okay all right
earth is in space I'm gonna remember
that remember that that's a good one
earth is in space Travis says there's
one big issue facing humans especially
in the third world countries is access
to clean drinking water is there a way
to possibly manufacture water through
chemistry or is it just not as simple as
throwing two hydrogen atoms together
with one oxygen atom is it even possible
to create water or is there a finite
amount available on earth that's a great
question it's a good question and you
know it's a huge problem for when we
want to explore the solar system because
if we're going somewhere else where
there's no water then we need to take it
with us or we need to pop by a comet or
an asteroid on the way and you know get
some water from it melt it you know take
it with us because we need water and
humans are not going to survive very
long without it so if we want to go to
Mars that again is one of the big
challenges for having humans on Mars
because to get water off the planet is
hugely expensive it's not very efficient
to get you know to launch stuff into
space so so this is a big problem we
need yeah we need to find a way to
either mine it on these planets if there
is any water but you know most of them
are bone dry that's a big problem but in
terms of the earth we have enough water
it's just in the wrong places most the
time if you know what I mean it's like
right we right exactly don't you think
we need to find a way to manufacture it
it's it's more of a way of getting clean
water we have a lot of salt water but
it's getting the clean fresh water in
the right places Lynne did you have
anything to add I just agree with
completely there's plenty of water but
too much or is it dirty or too much of
it is salty and we don't know where to
find more clean water and making the
dirty salty water clean is expensive
yeah but you can make water and I was so
excited when I did that in the lab the
first time we were doing experiments in
these little tubes and that inside the
tube was hydrogen and if you open the
tube and the hydrogen started to burn it
makes water because when you burn
hydrogen you adds the oxygen oxidizes
water Wow
and somehow making it and seeing the
drops of water fall down was kind of
mind-blowing to me because you do it
hypothetically you're like in your head
but this was for real we were burning
hydrogen and making water yeah and this
is why she's a scientist because we find
these kinds of things interesting that
is very interesting I mean honestly your
your your burning hydrogen to create
water is crazy and that's crazy that's
basically a James Taylor song you know I
mean that's really what it is so Wow
so now the fact that you've done this in
a lab if we ever got to a place where we
actually had to create water and this is
what what he was saying we would be able
to do that as Travis wants to know we
would be able to create water out of
nothing I guess and I think didn't they
do this in the Martian I don't know Matt
Damon was up there doing this wait a bit
wrong didn't air but you know your mind
you're burning hydrogen you got to be a
bit careful okay hey Travis great
question man that was very very cool
wait and let me put an addendum on his
question so you talked about salty water
water being in the wrong place you talk
about salty water you talk about dirty
water yeah is there now we'll never run
out of water ostensibly because
three-quarters of our planet is water
and we have a water cycle we have our
ecosystem is part is creates the water
cycle yeah is there a way if we stay on
our current course that we would
actually dirty enough water that we will
run out of water is that possible
yeah I guess yeah I don't see why not
because we're not very careful with it
and I guess at some point you know we
will have to find a way to make all the
water clean and that will be hard but we
could you know we can desalinate the
seawater is really expensive and it
takes a lot of energy to learn that
which is the main problem right yeah
Lindy yeah it's so the simple answer is
yes because it's a finite there's a
finite amount of water so you could make
it all dirty but the thing that I
learned recently that really shocked me
is most of the water that we get is from
wells it's from underground water you
know first right not only do we not know
how much water there isn't aquifers on
the earth almost none of that is is
legislated governments don't control how
much water you take out of aquifers
almost anywhere so we don't know how
much there is and we're not tracking it
and taking care of it wow that's worried
that's worrisome to say that that's a
crazy so what you're saying is there's
no regulation on the amount of
extraction but there's but there is also
no effort to measure how much is
actually there people are beginning to
work on it but we haven't we haven't
gotten there wow that's a that's I'm
just gonna say that's really stupid but
that's just my opinion okay we're trying
to grow up we're in a sort of an awkward
adolescence here but alright alright hey
well Travis that was a great question
man really really enjoyed that all right
here's a simple one and this is Tom
Rick's from Western Australia there's
never a simple question is cheaper
questions we'll just say this is a short
one that's a shortly I don't know if is
simple because our listeners they're not
simple people okay tree Tom Rick's wants
to know this is is a comet or is comet
water salty or fresh and can we find out
oh okay that's a nice question yeah so
um yeah we can find out definitely
because we can
go and measure measure the water it's in
the form of ice so we have to be able to
measure the ices but this comes off as
vapor when the comet goes via the Sun
and gets heated up so we can measure
either vapors with telescopes or we can
send a space mission and go measure
these things so this is definitely
something miserable and and we do do it
in terms of fresh or or salty I'm gonna
hazard a guess it's fresh I should
probably know this this is embarrassing
Lindy this is okay if you have salty
water and you frozen the ice would be
almost entirely fresh and so since the
water didn't start it started salty
water and it's frozen I think it's
mostly fresh but it's dirty
because yeah there's all kinds of other
ices and there are lots of rock
fragments and bits of minerals and lots
of organic matter lots of lots of
complex hydrocarbon biological building
blocks kind of stuff and so if you took
a whole comment and you melted it you
would definitely not want to drink it
yeah it would taste it speak for
yourself Lindy I'm saying is I can't
wait to drink it we don't just have
water ice on these comments because of
where they formed it's super cold you
can get other weird types of ice as well
a methane ice right and so you've you've
got a whole mixture so yeah if you could
just get the water ice itself you'd
probably be alright but yeah I'm not
sure I'd want to be drinking all the
methane water and stuff because there's
a lot of things that once you get to a
certain temperature they'll they'll
become ice temperature okay so and all
and all that's mixed in and when you say
mixed in are they are they mingled or
are they mixed in as if you have one
type of ice next to another complex
because you've got you've got the dust
in the comment and these are all kind of
fine-grained bits of rock kind of small
pieces of rock just the dust that form
the solar system but mixed into that
you've got organic material which we
kind of say it's kind of gloopy
it's like gloopy that's a scientific
term that it kind of holds stuff
together it's like a glue to hold these
these dust particles
otherwise the comment weight I wouldn't
just fall apart cuz it's not much acting
on it to make it fall apart but this
helps to stick the stuff together and
then we've got the ices now in terms of
understanding the distribution of those
ices through the body I don't think we
have a good idea about that at the
moment but the methane ice forms what we
call a clathrate it's a different is
kind of a different structure it's got a
different structure to normal ice and
that can actually you know have bits of
other material in it but you then have
the water ice as well I think yeah
they're probably closely associated
it'll depend on the particular area of
the comet and but yeah it will be dirty
it'll contain a lot of a lot of the dust
and the organic materials oh very cool I
don't know why but every time you said
Isis I had a patriotic urge to kick that
comets ass I'm sorry I'm sorry for that
everyone please I apologize all right we
got a quick one okay let's get a quick
run it and see I said it was sure and
you're right it wasn't simple it wasn't
it was a short question but it really
wasn't simple all right here we go
this is Heidi handler and Heidi says are
there any indications of possible
life-forms in the rocky material that
may be the source of water on earth so
that's all that's kind of a saying I
said simply that's a really cool
question and I don't know that you know
that certainly I don't know if we got
time for but that's a great question are
there any indications of possible
life-forms in the rocky material that
may be the source of water on earth a
lot of stuff packed into that question
okay so I think what we can do this is a
great question so Lindy do you want to
start answering this question we may run
out of time in the segment but we can
come back because I think there's
probably quite a lot to say so yeah so
the short answer is no there's not and
so and so actually we're teaching a
whole course about this in the fall to
try to begin to understand why not
because no one knows yeah wow that would
see that we did have time for that we
had time but then why you know this is
some of the questions we've got a to ask
occurs and you know this should be so
it is it's a really good question you
can leave it there and we're gonna take
a short break but we'll be back with
startled all-stars shortly
come back to Startalk all-stars I am dr.
Nathalie Starkey I'm still here with
Chuck nice Elkin Stanton and we are
getting some cosmic queries about water
in the solar system we've had a great
time so far trying to understand this
complex subject so let's move on since
you wouldn't have a question right here
okay I'm still reeling from the crystals
I'm telling you right now what wrong
it's like freaking me out and by the way
I for those of you listening and
watching us here on our video of connect
pal please look for my new erotic Rock &
Roll album born wet named by dr. Lindy
all right all right let us move on and
this is Jalen Paxton and Jalen is coming
to us from Twitter at jail impacts and
Jalen wants to know this what is the
feasibility of using comets to combat
freshwater shortage shortages on earth
in the future how we kind of talk about
the ISIS on a carpet actually no I mean
it's a good question because they do
contain a lot of water but actually
asteroids also contain a lot of water in
fact they could be you know tons and
tons of water and Astros more than than
in the earth itself so and they might be
easier to get to because we have quite a
lot of near-earth asteroids which are
close to us which we can get to quite
easily but I think as we've said earlier
it would be more useful to use those to
go elsewhere in the solar system because
we you know don't have a huge water
problem on earth at the moment so I
think if we want to go to those and mine
the water we can split it and use it for
hydrogen fuel or we can use it to drink
or survive there's even talks about the
best way to protect yourself in space is
it's from the radiation I think is to
coat a spacecraft in in a kind of volume
of rubble of water yeah a spacewalk
oh my god that's my second album so this
might be a way to do it you know use the
water from these asteroids or comets but
it's just you know they both contain
taking the water but actually the
asteroid is probably a better choice
because you might find there's more of
them nearer to us so yes that would be
okay all right
very cool very cool let us move on I'm
just laughing at the main electronic
janitor electronic janitor that's a very
cool handle something tells me he's an
IT guy who really hates his job he wants
to know this where other than earth have
we positively identified water like we
have here on earth okay but we have tons
of different types of water on earth
so I guess do the we we've got Freight
so we've got fresh water we've got salt
it's not water fresh water so yeah those
places is everywhere it's everywhere
just it depends if you want it as liquid
or or not but I mean we do there we
think there is liquids and loads of
other places so yeah so now here's what
I want to know based upon his question
for you and Lindy you know ice seems to
be the order of the day mm-hmm because
you know space is really really cold
yeah but where does the ice get to be
ice because it had to be someplace hot
and something else before it became that
ice on the asteroid or the comet okay so
where does that happen where does water
become the ice water right well you know
what is that is that in the formation of
something or what happens to make that
happen okay
Lindy do you want to sure I can tell you
what our best idea is although I don't
think we really understand this process
yet but it looks like when planets are
forming they started up just as a as a
as a rotating disc of gas and dust
around the young star we see this
elsewhere in the universe
even though ours is long gone and close
to the young star it's too hot for the
water to the ice but further away from
the young star
Isis form because it's cold even in that
early dust and gas discs and so some of
the ice could have been ice from the
beginning of the solar system and it was
never melted and then frozen again
oh how a guy look at that prime or du so
if we captured a comet we could drink
primordial ice from the origin of the
solar system so this is like Florida
that's a party I want to go to Lindy by
the way just like you're a little Ketel
One and primordial ice primordial rocks
please so I knew you could get the ice
made of different types of hydrogen so
if you got like the heavy ice then you'd
get potentially ice cubes that might
sink in your drink rather than float
nice all right very cool very cool okay
this is Chris Jacobs coming to us from
Twitter and Chris wants to know this do
you think we'll be mining from asteroids
or meteors in the very near future it's
a it's a good question because we have
now landed with feel a yeah so how far
are we from Ashley going in and mining
yeah that's really debatable because I
mean it's something that we've it's kind
of come to the forefront in the last few
years and there's a couple of kind of
private companies that are now looking
at actually doing space mining now
originally I think they were saying it
was gonna happen really soon and I think
as scientists we were all stood there
going Wow okay they're gonna do this
really quickly and that's going to be
very very impressive if they can do it
and I think their plans have been
slightly scaled back when they realized
that actually it is going to be a little
bit trickier than they thought they've
got to get the funding together but the
potential is that if they were to be
able to mine these things the return
economically is enormous so a small
investment to start with you know we're
still talking billions of
but you could potentially release many
many more billions of you know from
these asteroids if and there and that's
because you know of course you being a
geologist and inside of these asteroids
are the same elements yeah we find here
on earth exactly which means the rare
elements the ones that are really
expensive yeah we might be able to find
crap loads of there's so much up there
and you know whatever the precious
metals are so so important on earth for
making a lot of our electronics right
and there's a finite amount on earth you
know we're going to use it's in seams
and stuff and it's concentrated in
different areas that's what we mind in
different areas on the surface but with
an asteroids there's tons of this
material so the potential is that I mean
there's every potential that we can mine
these things but it's just going to be a
case of time and economics and then
we've got to decide how much we need say
platinum how much we need the platinum
and if we've run out in earth what price
it's got to on earth and whether it's
going to be economical to go into space
and make this happen so I think it is
gonna happen in the future and I think
it's going to be a case of hopefully
what I hope is private companies working
with space agencies so that we get some
scientific return from this but we also
get whatever we need economically so
yeah do you have anything to add Lindy
yeah I can't resist even models for how
they could go to a rocky asteroid take
some of the miracle water that's trapped
in the minerals and heat it up to
release the water it's so it's feasible
it's not economically viable that yet
like you say but the thing I like to
think about we're trying to go to an
iron a metal asteroid right now with a
mission to look at it and if we could
bring that back to earth you're running
it would be it would be the equivalent
of all the metals we've ever needed but
then you don't really make billions and
billions of dollars because what you do
is you collapse the global market yeah
because from an economics from an
economic standpoint if we had a crapload
of gold here on earth gold would no
longer be valuable
have to kind of retain it so they'd have
to be you know organizations that
retained it and released it as we need
otherwise yeah you wouldn't have cost
the fact is you would have to you would
own the asteroid and then you would
release the gold as necessary so you
were basically corner to market yeah on
whatever it is platinum gold or whatever
it is and then you would determine how
much you're going to release to set the
price for it and then there's other
problems with who owns this stuff
because it's space you know we
understand Earth we fight over who owns
bits of the earth and that's bad enough
but we're going to space well who owns
the stuff so if a private company goes
up a US company do is it a u.s. asteroid
then is it a whole is all US resources
or is it the global you know all I know
is if I land on that asteroid it's yours
and if you think it's not you can kiss
my asteroid okay okay okay let's go with
Lucas M Rodriguez and he wants to know
which of the two icy moons is more
likely to support life in your opinion
Europa or Enceladus okay so which one of
those two moons from those two planets
is more likely to have life that is G I
could not decide actually wit between
those they're both equate I'm gonna say
highly likely to they've got the right
conditions always so I I don't know do
you have any do you have an idea
III today I think both could I can't
immediately think of a reason why one
would be more likely than the other but
the the thing that troubles me about it
is that the very most likely place for
there to be life on them is at the
bottom of the water ocean next to the
rock okay I would well ever detect that
I don't know well I mean couldn't we
just so we've got to get through the ice
they both got an ice layer I guess on
the outside so we've got to get through
the ice with some kind of spacecraft and
drop it in and then get that to get to
the bottom of the ocean it's not very
easy because if it's deep you know we'd
find it hard to get to the bottom of our
you can't even get to the bottom of our
own ocean so it did
she's a crazy the conditions are gonna
be not very conducive to you know
getting so you know to get a
transmitting a signal back and to
understand what's there so so yes I
guess it's gonna be hard for us to tell
yeah well there you have it Lucas you
have just given our two scientists a
Sophie's Choice they cannot decide okay
both my babies must die that is
fantastic
what is our next question will come hey
wait let me see cuz I know we're running
out of time and I saw a cool question
from someone from the United Emirates
and I just lost it oh my god everywhere
and that is what is so cool I can't I'm
so sorry I just marked it and I can't oh
my god and there's only three pages here
it's not the hell just happened to me oh
my god ladies I'm having a stroke oh my
god what they wanted to know was can we
make a substitute for water that's
that's really what the question was
okay so is that can we make a substitute
for water so that when we are traveling
to someplace else instead of having the
weigh station can we make a substitute
for water for both here on earth and
from space travel and I'll look for
their name while you guys answer that
okay but I guess yes okay I get the
question but it's understanding like why
we need water and what water does on
earth and water acts as a solvent and
it's it's basically allows us to for
thing for reactions to happen so but and
there are other solvents as liquids that
can exist in the solar system that could
do the same job but we wouldn't be able
to drink them will survive on them that
doesn't mean that other life-forms
couldn't but we just haven't seen those
life-forms yet we have like just a
little bit of time Lindsey do you wanna
anything to this no I think you nailed
it there's nothing else that will do it
for people about water yeah so water is
it I mean we could make the substitute
but you know why would you right yeah
that's that's really the deal exactly
but it doesn't mean that other organisms
can do all organisms elsewhere alien
organisms might not need water that's
the thing but they need something that's
liquid that probably that is not going
to boil away and not going to freeze too
easily that they can survive in a for
McClatchy and by the way it came from
okay here's the name chirag jungler and
they've got you know quite a lot of
desert they're not much water going can
you can you can you just imagine why
someone from a Dubai might ask a
question of can we make a substitute for
water yes I'm so tired of eating saying
they've made a city out of but I'm
afraid that is oh we've got time for it
was fun it was a whirlwind yeah I agree
yep thank you so much you've been great
you've helped me with some tricky
questions please thank you that's very
happy but thank you so much and I'm
gonna thank Chuck nice my co-host you've
been fantastic but that's yeah all we
have time for today and but that's been
star talk all-stars I am dr. Nathalie
Starkey this is Startalk
[Music]
you